c'est vrai qu'en france on a un vrai
problème avec l'argent soit c'est
suspect soit soit il ya une biais de
longvic effectivement benjamin noval a
beaucoup parlé ici quand on voit une
très belle faut une très belle voiture
ben on la reille en france aux états
unis on se prend en photo devant disant
wahaha super un jour j'espère que je
pourrai mais a payé effectué moi je
pense était le salaire derrière des
chroniqueurs et voilà comme ça vous
attendiez riche hommage aux colocs
encore une fois le diktat de la
transparence de tout savoir pour toi
alors à ce moment là on va s'arrêter
belge il alors dit nous à ce moment là
toi combien tu gagnes et 600 euros par
émission je l'étais il a dit la vérité
il est dit on arrête la tronche et c'est
la vérité c'est l'amérique noire savoir
est ce que tu as une voiture combien de
voitures est ce que tu es propriétaire
est ce que tu étais mais m alors oui
mais je veux dire c'est que des gens si
vous presque totalitaire il ya des gens
qui nous l'ont reproché ici d'abord en
dehors nous reprocher de donner les
salaires de certaines personnes
puisqu'on est l'émission médias donc
forcément on l'a 2010 à bâle or puisque
vous l'avez donné sur les autres
pourquoi vous donnez pas pour vous
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ces
gens-là jean-michel moi je suis je
trouve c'est un peu tabou et pas pour
les mêmes raisons mes camarades mais
parce que je trouve que quand un parti
mais on sait que c'est tabou c'est parce
qu'on a conscience quand même qu'il ya
le fossé entre ceux qui viennent
beaucoup et ceux qui gagnent très peu il
est indécent quelque part mais
franchement moi je prouverai une
certaine gêne je l' ai déjà dit mon
salaire ici mais je trouve c'est vrai
c'est que ces contrats de salaire ni le
jour d'accord il parle car vous l'avez
dit jean michel ouazine l'est déjà
puisqu'il est un des plus anciens c'est
un magnifique salaires le trouve ça
énorme maison et non je sais moi j'ai le
souvenir de mon père je me suis inquiété
qui était chirurgien et quand il a joué
il avait oublié sa feuille de paie dans
la photocopieuse et c'est nous c'est une
infirmière qui leur a porté son sa
feuille de salaire il m'a dit j'ai eu
honte parce que je gagnais tellement par
rapport aux infirmières que ça m'a mis
une gêne que tu étais petit fils de
paysan
il m'a dit j'ai une telle eau de l'écart
de salaire entre les deux que ça m'a
gêné
voilà bah moi j'ai aussi ça te gêne un
peu